what's the best recipe for a successful
restaurant hurry up now it's going to be
called top friendships it looks
brilliant
the finest ingredients that is
incredible food Fit For A King is that
all for me La Riviera in Inverness seems
to have it all
done there's just one thing missing
[Music]
customers
without them you don't stand a chance
and I should know two years ago I had to
close my own restaurant in Scotland I'm
just worried that you don't fall into
the same [__] trap that I did and I
lost a lot of money this week Kitchen
Nightmares gets personal it's been the
biggest wake-up call in my entire life
okay
Scotland home of the brave home two of
Haggis neets and tatties and the Deep
five miles bar
but in Inverness there's a restaurant on
a mission to bring sophisticated French
cooking to my fellow Countryman okay you
send me to prestata right now please
it's the vision of French head chef
Louis Lafayette
who's trained in some of the best
kitchens in France
I went to work for the president in
France Mr Shirak when we had like Mr
Bush is coming our Japanese president is
coming he used to do like big function
service once level 14 go then I moved to
work with the poster Boza and Napoleon
and there are three Mission Stars
I can't wait to meet a young chef with
such an impressive pedigree
help realize his dream Lewis hand-picked
an impeccably trained Brigade
sous chef Jeffrey has worked in
restaurants with both one and two
Michelin stars did you work with Louis
in France no no
I actually basically here because it's a
very good opportunity to work on some of
these three Mission staff Regis also has
a Michelin star studied background how
long have you been cooking
uh eight years in France and in a
different country you know
and so does the junior of the team
Nicola
not letting the side down either his
previous jobs were at Michelin star
level as well
Scottish girlfriends uh yes my French
accent
1400 miles from the French Riviera Louis
has created a mini French stronghold in
Inverness and no one Scottish in the
kitchen
no Scottish awesome but not anymore did
you stack them no no no no no first time
when I came in the kitchen I switch off
the microwave
to the car park and three days after I
was by myself I got a message yeah
because they were using microwave all
the time uh powder for stock
deprying everything even fondant
potatoes
so I had to build a new team which is
good
Louis determined that his dream team is
going to get him his barrier in Michigan
when he wanted to get the Premiership
title he went round and got the best
manager the best football players and
then brought them all over to Chelsea
yeah fantastic yeah
done I think if you can get a Michelin
star
actually be great for us we are looking
to achieve like one Michelin staff to
start with why not two and you know
even the fridge is top of the league wow
walking in the fridge [__] look at
the size of it it's like a one bedroom
flat and the produce is the very best
flying vegetables in from France is over
the top even for me but the local
shellfish is really Top Notch they are
amazing
when they come down to London they're
definitely not that fresh I can show you
that is incredible
[__] me they've got the best of
everything you hear I mean really the
best of everything someone must be
playing a small [__] fortune to run
this place and that someone is
multi-millionaire Barry Larson hop from
a 600 acre private shooting estate
he made his fortune from the catering
business but it wasn't exactly fine
dining morning Julie how are you this is
the man who brought Kentucky Fried
Chicken wimpy and Harry ramsden to
Scotland
and now he's invested nearly 2 million
pounds trying to prove he can make fine
dining Finger Licking Good sounds
amazing the sort of dream team that
you've put together you know slightly
concerned about the expense involved in
that because
stream teams don't come cheap you
haven't got any gray hair so I've got
some yeah well you're hiding it very
well unless you died
not yet
um but no it's expensive you know what
the school is yeah big time have you
owned hotels
no no I haven't owned uh hotels before
we've had various restaurants fast food
chains that we've built up sold out
family restaurants that we we still run
but obviously at a different completely
different level I mean fast food
restaurants miles away from anything to
do with fine dining yeah but you know
you still want to produce quality yeah
for the for the spend it sounds
fantastic but this place is costing
Barry over 8 000 pounds a week on food
and staff costs alone
and they seem to have forgotten the
three most important things in the
restaurant business
[Music]
customers customers
four days a week
and one cheese sandwich and every night
it's empty it's another big dent in
Barry's investment and Luigi's CEO
sometimes you get zero really yeah it
must be hard that one is zero
especially all this team here it's a
nightmare for us because it hurts yeah
you've got the team but you want to play
you're ready to go but oh yeah
that's difficult we are like dogs you
know uh when they go shooting yeah we
are ready Louis hungry for success but
the locals aren't biting can you do me a
favor can you um read that out for me
please
do what that is
one glance at his menu and I think I've
spotted the problem before I've even
tasted the food not sure declinized
[Laughter]
what do you think that means this food
May appeal to the connoisseurs in the
south of France but this is Scotland's
smallest city yeah would you eat that
would I eat it
nice to meet you Barry and lewick won
Michelin level success but I'm afraid
they've lost sight of the basics you are
an impatient bastard yeah
you you you you you you want you want it
and you want to get your shopping
trolling go along and get that and get
that and yeah I can see it in your eyes
you've had a lot of success beforehand
bringing all these things in together
it's not the perfect recipe for an
instant hit right I'm just worried that
you don't fall into the same [__]
trap that I did and I lost a lot of
money right
it was a proud day for me when I opened
amaryllis in my hometown Glasgow
we got off to a great start and within
our first year we'd won a Michelin star
but as the menu became more elaborate
the diners started to dwindle the food
was so fancy it put off the locals they
stopped coming
and I was forced to close amaryllis down
there's a bit of a Deja Vu for me and
I'm concerned that you may be running
right too quickly too soon you know
you're in danger I [__] it's going
too far
that happened to me after 12 years at
the top I saw
there's no doubt in Louis Talent
it's his lack of experience that worries
me one's Caleb level three it's his
first ever head Chef's job there's
always a big big trap they fall in are
we doing it well they're trying to do
too much too soon and almost try to be
sort of competitive and thinking that
what they saw in their previous kitchen
which was in a three Mission star I've
got to be better than that and that's
where a lot of young chefs fail
could you check double ten for me please
[Music]
it's my second day at Le Riviera a top
restaurant with no customers
so if the locals aren't eating here
where are they eating busy for lunch
[__] me 5.95 for two courses start
around me
Inverness is a fast-growing City and the
restaurant Market is clearly thriving
7.95 is a [__] achievement early
summer menu two courses 9.95
I've asked Louis to serve me dinner from
his a la carte menu which costs 34
pounds for two courses with that team in
there and the produce in the fridge is
to die for
um so it should be a great dinner 140
this one one scale up to 401k the bread
pink yes yes all right let's go this is
your cannabis you have an olive
Medallion and a cheese beignet canopies
and a pre-starter this is ambitious food
for London let alone Inverness
potato soup
with um wasabi
very creamy
very very rich
yeah I'm excited about the food but I
don't feel comfortable sitting here
you are like a painter you need you did
not you need a good eye you know like
the painting will put something like
black Air and not here because for him
doesn't look right okay
let's go once collapse table nine
a lot of a lot of combinations of
flavors going on
for me the golden rule is always keep it
simple you're tasting a broad bean and
white asparagus and citrus vinaigrette
coffee tomato fennel seeds fennel
flowers sherbil salad parmesan there
must be 20 things going on this plate
and then yeah that looks fantastic but
next up duck on door service
decided to make it a ravioli
a good and 10. 12 flavors on the plate
again it's just confusion and your mind
is sort of working overtime to try and
understand what's happening okay service
please a main course serves in two parts
that's just pretentious almost like
someone
um
is uncontrollable and almost like a
little bit carried away and
um over excited and nothing sane just
stop come back
Allah is that all for me yes Louis seems
desperate to impress next they'll be
telling me how to eat it if I may to
recommend you the order you've got the
tiramisu fast please then the floating
island then you'll have the souffle then
finally the carnito with Mommy well out
of bonds next one we told which
adaptation to pee in because of the
[__] salmon in the river
technically
flavors were amazing the scallops were
delicious
the light vinaigrette yeah and didn't
need the parmesan didn't need the
flowers and do you need that many
flavors to make it work I won't change
anything on the flavor of icing the way
we work the product
um bring to the guests the flavors and I
want your personality
has to be comfortable on the plate
and I see a lot of uneasiness on the
plate I don't know if you're confident
enough of what you're doing and I've got
to be very honest because this is very
crucial but this this this has to work
Barry what do you think when you think
about it
it's probably right that he has to
just find his own style Barry's acting
more like a besotted sugar daddy than
Luke's boss
you take on somebody like that and
you're taking them on because of their
capabilities and their ambition and you
know the last thing I want to try and do
is restrain that ambition and and what
he's doing I'm not you know I'm not the
chef and I couldn't do what he does I'm
not really in a position to criticize
one Grill but I am this place isn't even
breaking even and yet Barry's forking
out four and a half Grand a week just on
staff
no way to run a successful business
Barry's in love with you
no no no he's in love with your food
um yeah I seem to like it yeah he's
never going to be your critic and what
I've got to understand is where is your
critic coming from I was telling you to
stop that's it send it when I think it's
all right don't touch it anymore it goes
It goes no wonder his food's over the
top
[Music]
now I want to see how he runs his
kitchen
[Music]
Jesus
as every play Journeys around the
kitchen each of his seven chefs adds
another flourish
and all this unnecessary fussing is
wasting time and money
hurry up now
yeah well done
there's so many hands are going on
around the kitchen the plate is that
normal for to go around can they not
finish anything it's just my sauce it's
the same for the laptops and in my sauce
okay you put the plate under the grill
and I sauce okay
up up one is missing no no no it's okay
it's okay sorry okay
now it feels like you've done 250 and
we've cooked in the last
um two and a half hours and 10. please I
felt that I wanted to just say stop what
you've got at the beginning was just
enough for me
simple because the ingredients you've
got are phenomenal
he needs to let his food speak for
itself his approach feels outdated and
pretentious
maybe crooked
and do through it together that way
right now what should we do
scallops
um now now whatever
um I've got a few things to do okay for
the guest tonight and I'll be with you
okay
if the Russian was full I could
understand his arrogance but his
hemorrhaging cash and no one seems to
care it's almost like the barricades are
up and you know nothing's going to get
through because all I want to do is do
this together and look at the different
stages we're taking out to make it more
appealing but it doesn't seem to sort of
sink in I think it would be part of the
team just let me in
touch yourself being hard asses yeah
nice but winning this situation with
over complex food and no direction I
[__] grab that kind of insight if I
was in his shoes
trust me completely I can do what I want
whatever I want so
it was a deal between us
cast of Blanche and whatever I do
Luke's behaving like a spoiled brat so
as a last resort I'll try his Brigade
is there something you can you know work
closely with Louis yeah
you cannot help us as well I'm sure I
want to help yeah definitely let me
[__] in yes first I'm going to tackle
the language barrier
fluent Scottish
it's food in Scottish now all right so
when someone upsets him in the High
Street
office
Pizza no piss off piss off out of my way
oh [__] it yeah
I'm making Headway with the team and
perhaps I can get through to luig if
we're on neutral ground are you familiar
with any of the songs do you know what
they sing here
I wouldn't shout out here
[Music]
I'm not sure the locals will appreciate
French football songs any more than
they'll appreciate Lewis food
I look at your situation and I can't
stop comparing it to my situation when I
opened up in my hometown in Glasgow
got too serious and then everybody was
scared to come and then we lost a lot of
money and you know
what's the point in keeping your
restaurant open if you're losing money
and it broke my heart and that was my
hometown I was born there
you know I don't want to see happen with
you you're running the Riviera
um like a three Michelin star
establishment you started at such a high
level
I don't know if it's such a high level I
mean
when you practice with
I mean like your chefs when the parties
with you one day they will go by their
own absolutely what do you think they're
gonna do
yeah that's a good question um fish I
know but you've got to start with the
locals it's not going to survive unless
that restaurant's full
so what do the locals want some mustard
or ketchup uh
steak sandwich
hmm
that's not bad though isn't it
and when you've got such good local
produce you don't need to mess with it
I'm giving my change back did it
no see he's really Scottish
it's already my third day but nothing's
sinking in surely Lou it can't ignore
the evidence if it's staring him in the
face
this isn't a meal for six all this is
dinner for one at La Riviera looks like
a [__] face for a king
Henry the eighth huh
it's quite interesting when you um start
from one end and go all the way right to
the very end it helps you to identify
where you can just draw back a little
bit
and look at the whole balance of exactly
what you're doing and people have to
understand then they are here to enjoy
it so they have to spend a bit more time
on the table like just say okay we've
got two hour and a half yeah to enjoy it
I couldn't eat all that
I I I'd have to stop halfway I think I'd
stop halfway
yes
I don't know
[Music]
um
ifas was not able to to eat all this I
wouldn't do it
what Louis can't get into his stubborn
French brain is that refusing to trust
these ingredients isn't just putting off
his customers
it's also a turn off for Michelin
inspectors
maybe I can convince Barry it is his
money after all recommend me a whiskey
I'll try to explain in terms that any
hot-blooded Scotsman will understand and
one for uh Barry please Barry's paying
so
no because you're going to spoil the
complicated the drinks are you
suggesting or telling me
um doing both and no way soda on the
watch species there's no way
no
let me just say something
you're absolutely right
you don't [__] with things that are good
and the first thing I said to live it
about the food when you've got quality
ingredients let them
speak for themselves so and when you've
got something as good as that it speaks
volumes doesn't need anything else no
[__] party no shovel no bailiff no
[__] fruit Garden nothing just bent
get it out
do you understand yeah I do Barry seems
to be getting it and I've got an idea
that just might convince his Chef the
sanjack dish I want you to cook that I'm
going to cook a sanjack dish alongside
you there's a lot of way to do it I mean
like yeah no no no
of course you know it's just I'm 38 I'm
10 years older you know yeah and so it's
not because I'm [__] 10 times better
I just want to make you understand how I
speak yeah okay okay what Newark doesn't
know is that I've invited ex-a inspector
David Young to judge the dishes for
himself
and what he won't know is whose is whose
mice and Jack dish has just four simple
ingredients as well as the scallops it
has a cauliflower puree and a caper and
raisin dressing
[Music]
Louis dish has at least 14 different
flavors so you've got the new season
asparagus white asparagus with the Roses
scallops you've got a funnel artichoke
and Anis Jew and I mix it with the
fennel milk okay you've got the
Parmesan crisps and you've got the broom
it's time to let Louis Into My Little
Secret I've arranged for the inspector
guide to come and taste our food Thank
You Go Darling please
inspectors are feared and revered by
chefs all over the country if they judge
your food worthy of missionary stars or
AAA rosettes the reward is a place on
the gastronic map
and ideally customers beating a path to
your door
thank you Willie prefer Lewis elaborate
plateful or my simpler rendition
this particular one has much more visual
impact I get the feeling that the dish
is going to taste of exactly what was
described to me
whereas this one looks a little bit over
garnished and there's a bit of a model
of different types of flavors inspectors
like David can make or break a
restaurant's reputation
if Luke is going to gain a covered
admission in Star his food really needs
to be worthy of four rosettes
how difficult David is it to get four AA
rosettes well it's very difficult
because to put it into context as at
this moment there are only two aa4s at
restaurants in Scotland in the whole of
Scotland in the whole of Scotland is it
a four-star dish what you've eaten
this one going yeah no no this
particular dish would be somewhere
between two and three rosettes whereas
this dish would be probably four
rosettes a combination of the
cauliflower and Caper puree just
absolutely lifted addition to a
different dimension whereas this one
some of the flavors were over
complicated to to be frank about it and
it may be just a case of sometimes
um less is actually more
Louis has taken the news badly
he thinks I've stitched him up
anglo-fence relations
have hit an all-time low
but time is running out at the Riviera
it's got to work hasn't it it's your
first attention
I can't afford to [__] that will I ever
make princess out of this colony of
frogs
it doesn't I'm getting towards the end
of my week at La Riviera
and I don't know if luik is still
speaking to me
last night he reacted badly when an AAA
inspector confirmed that his food was
over fussy what was the first thing you
thought about this morning after
um yesterday with the inspector what was
the what's one message you
you learn from it
um
now I have your advice I had
his advice as well so
one you can say maybe it's wrong two
start to take care of that maybe I am
wrong
so it's a difficult thing to accept
the French franc has finally dropped
it's been hard for Louis but he's
already changing his game plan he's come
up with a new much simpler idea of the
scallop dish it looks [__] brilliant
and what I can identify now I know
there's Apple because you kept the green
on there I know there's rocket I know
there's pumpkin seed and it makes me
feel comfortable because I know what I'm
about to eat yeah I can identify what
you're doing
that
that's delicious everything that goes on
the plate has to
have a reason not for this but for here
yeah for the palette and what you've
just done there lyric you've given your
food clear Insight okay
I understand and it's not three four or
five or is that for me I'd be happy
eating that anyway you know that where's
that [__] inspector
turn
[__] you know Hallelujah I've just taken
[__] France now lyric has finally
swallowed his pride we can begin to move
forward
with his team behind him maybe he has a
chance of achieving his ultimate goal
um he told me
that you wanted a Michelin star
and at first I didn't think that was
possible you know that because of how
things got so complicated
but with this here
there's no two ways about it it's
definitely worth the start
I respect Louis for taking it on board
because it's [__] hard lesson very
hard lesson but you know
it's got to work hasn't it it's your
first head to the job yeah you can't
afford to [__] that crucial you've got
the right training now you've got the
perfect position to do it
but winning over the kitchen is only
half the battle
Carolyn is the Maita D and she's also
Louis's girlfriend
she's responsible for writing the
elaborate menus and have already
discovered that the locals haven't got a
clue what they mean it's time to turn
the tables read that for me
nice color
nothing we must do to prove a point I've
given them a menu of classic Scottish
dishes what do you think it is something
sexy uh something spicy that is
Luke what do you think that one is there
this one here Rudy's for far and we talk
about inside of grills
no idea at all what is Queen Mary Queen
Marita and
we paid Canada crunch to have any idea
what I'm trying to say it's impossible
to choose anything you don't understand
exactly that's exactly it's difficult
for make a choice when you have this one
because yes it's difficult for [__]
in Scotland to understand you guys yeah
that's what I'm trying to say yeah same
yeah so it's less intimidating if you
have an assortment of salmon
um you know a selection of Mandarin do
you understand what I'm trying to say
yeah at last I'm getting somewhere just
look at what you're taking to the table
and [__] out you know it's like
you're a librarian
you should see what it's like when the
table are sat
and six of them are looking in here
you've lost everybody yeah yeah there's
no dinner anymore because everyone's
behind a brick wall you can simplify the
whole thing just one beautiful open card
starters Mains so everything going down
there is simplified it
and it's not just the menus that need
lighting up
smile he's far better looking when he's
smiling
[__] hell it doesn't cost anything in
Scotland
well it's right yeah oh [__] now
throw him in the river
church service
where's my Bible
Barry's grass the nettle and has radical
plans to transform the dining room
I'm gonna take this column away yep I'm
going to take the raised area away at
the back on that side so we've got it at
a cost of 35
000 pounds The Archers over the doors
were going to Square Off
yeah and then it's all paddled all the
way around it's the most artwork it
doesn't look that bad does it
doesn't look I don't think it looks
particularly
it's not glamorous but it's not
glamorous but it's shitty no but it's
just not I just think it doesn't look
right
but I've got a low-cost idea which I
think will give lariviera a unique
selling point
I'd like you to start thinking about
having a table in the kitchen
where you have local to come and sit and
eat yeah it starts to break up the sort
of wall that you know sometimes you have
when you come to a strange new country
as I've discovered having a chef table
in the kitchen is a great way to bring
customers into your world and keeping
the chefs on their toes
and this would be the first restaurant
in Scotland to have one
I think this this will be the best place
yeah just in a corner and they will see
everything everything and it can help
create something exciting Inverness can
you imagine the bus going round town the
chef's table could be a way of showing
off and establishing your reputation
here and be be first yeah yeah I think
it's exciting idea yeah it is yeah yeah
I mean for once we're gonna see how do
the people really react to your food if
it's no good I mean like just to throw
it yeah
hopefully they won't do that
but it all costs money and although the
chef table is a great investment until
they've got customers coming in they
need to make economies elsewhere crap
Fogo
and hand dive scallops which are King
scallops so I mean the Rolls-Royce of
ingredients I mean everything's here
[__] out
luig needs to do what I did when I
started out learn to use good cheap cuts
to put together an inspiring menu
making something Exquisite from a shin
of beef or an ox tongue takes a lot of
skill by the size of my feet
and it's a great way to identify Talent
right
um
oxtail
you you and you Bridges a little
competition I want you to cook a dish
come up with something really exciting
and then lyric myself will look at it
and the most
tastiest
delicious dish we'll put on the lunch
menu and for me the most important thing
about this is always a sign of a very
very good cook to turn something very
very cheap into something quite special
so
we're just take it to bed and think
about it
next morning I'm pleased to see the
young chefs have taken their oxtail
challenge seriously what's that yes
it's very you know yeah nice enough yeah
yep roll it put it back into still a
shape from the beginning yeah
[Music]
the oxtail dishes for the lunch menu are
almost ready and they've each cost about
a quid to put together so this is
winter vegetable Bridge Terminators
dishes like these are not only highly
profitable but bringing together great
Scottish produce with French Flair is a
winning formula zoo and just a bit of
yes tastes delicious with the white
brewed vegetables it made it feel earthy
and and together yeah who's next and
despite what Louis thinks simplifying
his dishes will actually make them more
likely to win Awards
I've never had Oxo and sesame seed
together before Mission inspectors never
reveal their criteria but I know from
experience that beautifully cooked food
is not enough next inspectors look for
good quality ingredients ideally
Regional and definitely in season
this idea is great and the balance of
flavors is crucial very rich
it needs a salad yeah because it's quite
rich and what I like is that if you put
the salad just next to and not on a
plate like this you can choose Thank you
first and foremost don't confuse a
mission inspector's palette by putting
too many ingredients on the plate never
expected any more friends to come up
with a chicken potato stuffed it thank
you the simpler the better
um what do you think
what you managed to do is to bring out
the true flavor of oxtail
thank you okay Mel Gibson I need one of
these dishes would be worthy of a place
on the lunch menu but we're choosing
just one I want to see if Luke and I
will agree on the winner I'm going to
touch my plate which I'd like on the
lunch menu you touched it later after
three yeah okay one two three
it was real and authentic
Scottish food yep that's I think he
understood really understood where we
want to go with Louis leading the way
we're ready to relaunch the restaurant
for me it's a critical stage for any
restaurant to get a lunch full and if
our customers have an enjoyable lunch
chances are they'll be back for a more
expensive a la carte dinner when they
leave with a bloody good lunch
good prices I can guarantee
by the time five o'clock in the
afternoon hits
you know they've told 100 people
go there for dinner because I had a
fantastic lunch I want to see if we can
push their starter
Main and dessert one hour yeah
[Music]
as well as the new oxtail dish the menu
will include mackerel pheasant and ghost
cheese ravioli venison from Barry's
estate tuna and the cheapest cut of pork
chasmine sometimes are scared about
belly of Paul thinking fat greasy we've
taken the fat off rolled it and spiced
on a bed of spinach it's a caramelized
onion puree have a taste if you wish
[Music]
and I've got some other ideas to give
Scottish traditional dishes a modern
twist this is a soup that doesn't look
pretty but tastes amazing they wouldn't
expect the Frenchman to make a coconut
soup which is a really nice way of
putting your identification on it
just an idea for the rice pudding yeah
we grew up with this kind of food so we
can go a little bit further caramelize
pineapple mango or even marinade the
prunes in a nice small whiskey yeah
[Music]
the kitchen's finally turning out the
kind of food that I know will definitely
appeal to the locals
and even the waiters have promised to
try and smile
but there's one more thing to complete
the transformation you've got to come
with me now
because we're going to become even more
Scottish
[Applause]
[Music]
any ideas yet
Bridges have you ever taken your
knickers off before no no chance to show
aim with us your Scotch eggs okay it's
time for lyric and his small colony of
French comrades to surrender themselves
to the Scots
[Music]
the things I'll do to get the Arrogant
French to become a little bit more
Scottish is amazing you know that it's
cold
we don't wear pants
it's wonderful very odd and it's very
sexy
there's 25 very important guests coming
for lunch yes for some really good news
they're all women
very powerful women
if they can impress 25 influential local
business women they'll be the Talk of
the Town
legs
[Music]
[Applause]
at last Lux team will begin to dance to
a different tune
[Music]
the food looks really good clear and
simple
have everyone's going really really well
it was the first time I've actually seen
a real taste of Scotland
in this kitchen about [__] time
Lewis on his way to the top of the
Premier League
[Music]
and judging by the reaction of his fans
he's definitely scored absolutely Divine
just perfect absolutely perfect
you couldn't Bowl anything really I
would imagine normally this sort of food
you'd be talking at least a couple of
hours for lunch but to get something
like this in that time skill brilliant
it's beautiful
as well I've tried you win this
okay it's for you will present thank you
excuse me what the [__] is that
I think it's a big chef and what is that
there oh
yeah trust me I have a big pair of
Pollocks Hallelujah blue yeah thank you
yeah
and his team have come a long way this
week and if he sticks to my keep it
simple Mantra and I think Le Riviera
might be on the right track for a
Michelin star
outside
[Applause]
just for the ladies
to understand that you really are part
of Scotland now we're all going to turn
around
[Applause]
right luick
it's been two months since I was at La
Riviera
have you missed me a little bit yeah so
what's changed
the menu looks lovely and you've got
cheaper ingredients on Ox cheek for the
lunch menu yeah I'm dying to taste the
Portuguese can you cook me one please
yeah yeah with the uh risotto yeah it
looks lovely oh yeah it's very nice
that looks interesting is that the
chef's table yes
very impressed with that that is great
yeah
he's acted on my advice
but the proof of the pudding is in the
eating
a lyric
um
a dish with just four ingredients
absolutely delicious that for me so far
is one of the most tasty dishes I've
ever eaten here really really delicious
if you continue like this this place is
only going to just get busier and busier
and busier that's what we want that's a
great dish to be proud of
has the refurb been going on in the
dining room dining room
I mean what a difference
I don't know it looks a lot more
um slick smart sorry must have spent a
fortune on it beautiful uh dark panel
wood um a completely different dining
room
it is it is it feels more relaxed but is
it money well spent
has anything improved since the last
time I was here yeah the restaurants
bookings have improved we've just you
know looked at what you told us on
simplifying the menu right in the menu
permission sir I would love to get one
but what's more important for me at the
moment is that we build the customers
it's certainly come a long way from the
restaurant I found two months ago
food was so elaborate
things going on it had frightened off
the customers
hurry up now he was desperate for a
mission to start but reluctant to let me
help
but by the end of the week we're just
take it to bed and think about it the
message had sunk in Hallelujah I've just
taken [__] France and we were able to
fill the stuffy restaurant with happy
diners
his dream was to win Awards and with his
newly simplified food I thought Louis
was finally producing dishes worthy of a
missionary staff
it looks [__] brilliant where's that
[__] inspector
turn this time round I raised the bar
even higher with another surprise
visitor for luik last time I saw this
man he actually gave me three Mission
Stars so
um perhaps the most revered and feared
critic in the world
Derek Brown is the grand fromage of
restaurant inspectors hi Derek he's the
ex-president of the Michelin guy and
he's agreed to do me a favor um I'm not
going to say too much about this
particular restaurant
um he's a very
intriguing Talent individual and just
would love to see what you think what
he's capable of doing yeah now remember
you don't know me don't know yourself
head chef Louis has no idea he has such
an influential critic in his restaurant
sake I hope Derek goes for the simple
pork cheek I have
how would you like it
um pink pink
to me the Scottish land with stuffed
baby artichokes looks just as elaborate
as it did two months ago I see you've
got your home Garden back
is very important for me I hope to God
I'm wrong you can't eat it
got it
I can't wait to see lewin's face when he
realizes that the food he's sending out
now is for the ex-president of Michelin
he's going to [__] his French knickers
time for the Moment of Truth
do you know this anyone
no
I'm Mr Derek Brown lyric I think I've
seen you yeah yes maybe in France
somewhere I'm dying to find out I'm sure
Luke as well how was lunch well it was
very interesting your Technique I mean
you've been very careful about the whole
preparation of each of your dishes but
you know it was too complicated there
were 10 different flavors on the plate
there was garlic and herbs in the
artichoke which is itself a delicate
thing a little bit overpowering I
thought the shoulder which you've done
at cornfield that was the tastiest part
of the dish the million dollar question
it was lunch worthy of a Michelin star I
would I would say that you you have not
got very far to go I never gave advice
in my working life before but if you
want me to give you some reason I would
simplify what you're doing make sure
that the customers are going to be happy
with every dish that you ever make them
and things like stars from The Michelin
guide will follow the old boys have got
to be replaced so it's up to you and and
you've got the talent just just use it
and refine it mm-hmm
but has the message really sunk in or is
he still intent on forcing over
elaborate French food on the locals
yeah yeah that's why you have to make
something really special [__] me I mean
my my frustrating thing is that they've
really got to understand the message
because you know I [__] said this
from day one and I'm not an inspector
I'm a chef and I see it from your level
will he ever understand that simple can
also be special one sermon one vanism so
are you feeling a little nervous about
the chef's table in the kitchen tonight
for the first time if they see a
nightmare
you're gonna say look this [__]
French is [__] crazy no I think
they'll be very happy with the [__]
nightmare with a fully book Russian
tonight
and his first diners in the kitchen
lyric should be a very happy man okay
good evening good evening so I hope
you're glad to be the first in my
kitchen table I will make you a bit of
music for you if you want I can I can
manage it never be the best of Mayors
but we do have one thing in common
ambition remember what you said that
thing about 12 or 15 things on one plate
yeah so next time you put a dish
together
and you've gone past eight nine ten
things on the plate give me a [__]
call because I'm coming back when you
get to 11. okay
yes good luck tonight yes because I
think you're gonna [__] need it
I sincerely hope he makes it a success
who knows maybe the Michelin star will
follow
[Music]
guys
Mama Sherry's Soul Food shack has hit
rock bottom we have put so much of our
own money in it known it we no longer
have it the customers just aren't biting
ten plus one Saturday lunchtime and this
place should be absolutely round there's
too many cooks doing all the wrong
things
you turn up for work half an hour late
in my kitchen you'd be home for the day
looking for a new [__] job turn this
into a professional outfit within a week
that would take a miracle I've
definitely got
it's time to get serious if you don't
break away from this stove I swear to
God the business is gonna close you need
young man eggs [__] rocket up your
ass
I'm not going to lose my business
Brighton London by the Sea loads of
locals and a steady stream of hungry
tourists
nesting just a stone's throw away from
the seafront is Mama Sherry's Soul Food
shack offering Classics on America's
Deep South oh nice nice nice the big
Soul Mama AKA Sharita Jones has raised
33 foster children but running her first
restaurant is proving a far bigger
handful it's all going to just kind of
go and fall apart so I don't want it to
fall apart
it's definitely a Shack on the outside
anyway
top Caravan
is this it
[Music]
Sharita Sharita Gordon good to see you
nice to see you this is how small it's
quaint it's cozy I'll say it's like
walking it's like walking into your
front Lounge thank you and that's what
it's supposed to be about because I tend
to spend all my life here this has got
to be my front room otherwise when do I
get to kick my feet up after three and a
half years despite throwing everything
at this place and working seven days a
week Sharita is still in serious debt to
the tune of 65 000 pounds
and who's the chef
I'm
I'm pound of big mamas and all of them
it's called stick to your ribs basically
stick to your roots ribs a ribs see your
ribs
mama Sherry Shack seats 40 at an
extremely intimate squeeze
sadly for Sharita that's not often a
problem as weekday trade it's virtually
non-existent it's great at the weekend
somehow we've discovered that we're in a
hole we're just in this hole a financial
hole that we can't claw our way out of
have you made any money since you've
been open nope not a penny not a single
penny have we made since we've been open
it's hard to put our finger on why is it
critical I mean how long how long can
you continue staying like this
truthfully truthfully I'd say
three to six months maximum maximum no
customers no money buying your head
right it's time to check out the kitchen
God
Sharita calls herself the cook but Brian
moyo is a head chef so who's in charge
how you doing dude all right thank you
do you do this and all that and Poland
uh I try not to
why
um I'm confused well I
I was employed to Come As a head chef
right but because of uh problems with
financing don't let me stop it I took a
sit back so who writes the menu uh
Sharita has written everything she does
everything basically she got a cushy job
then really haven't you you could say
that as a chef yes pretty chill yeah as
a chef yes it's pretty sure that's it I
had Chef who doesn't write the menu and
only works 35 hours a week next he'll be
telling me he's forgotten how to cook
here you go
I got some catfish goujons with Hush
Puppy in our homemade pineapple salsa
it's actually quite nice very um very
delicate fish and um it's nicely fried
very light really nice
thank you be back with your Mains
good for Maze My Plate's piled high with
a clumsy mess of ribs spicy chicken
jambalaya and corn and bean succotash I
hope he likes it
hmm
[__] now there's ribs
so tender
have to say it's throwing the plate
this may be the first time I should go
back to the kitchen with an empty plate
thank you
um thank you bloody delicious thank you
and you know what thank you I thought
it's gonna be really spicy but let's
turn it down and it was spot on and it
actually made me feel like I was back at
mum's for the first time oh and having
some home cooking it was very good oh
don't get me crying
there are things I would change okay I'm
happy to hear about in general I can't
take a picture of this place
I know it sounds crazy I know it sounds
crazy
oh God I fed Gordon Ramsay
and he cleaned his place how the hell do
you turn that thing off she doesn't shut
up
rabbit rabbit rabbit rabbit
[__]
sharita's down-home style should be a
unique selling point but it ain't
working
I need to go back to the kitchen and
find out why
Friday and should we just tackling most
of the day's preparation single-handedly
in a desperate bid to save money part of
this is you know you've got to get your
hands dirty yeah of course
marinating meat making dressings sauces
and bacon are all crucial things to
prepare in advance of a busy service Mr
shaking off the excess but deep fried
chicken wings eight hours in advance of
their first booking that can't be right
so why'd you cook them now because if
you cook them off now and leave them to
cool when the order comes in it's just a
matter of picking out how many we need
and they go back in and they come back
up to a nice and they don't go dry no no
I'm beginning to suspect the good old
home cooking isn't as wholesome as it
could be
most of it's coming from the freezer
rather than the soul too much how many
freezers we got 13 freezing fruits [__]
me
by the time Brian turns up there's not
much left for him to do so you can't
really feel like your head chef if
you've got cheetah in the kitchen every
morning cooking the food and you come in
a sense that you're not actually really
cooking you're just coming in and
putting things together yes
have you lost motivation
yes
so if sharita's head Chef's gone off the
boil I'm hoping her remaining crew of
part-timers have a bit more spunk
heading up front of house with Lauren
she arrives 10 minutes late for the
evening service
20 year old 80 seems to be more
committed to his glamorous day job so
why panel beat it
finish at all four every day kitchen
Porter Gavin lives next door but he
appears to turn up when he feels like it
sharita's librarian husband Phil hot
foots it back from the day job to become
basement Barman and resident DJ it looks
like your washer offer no way he does
that as well
these are numerous other part-time staff
are all members of Mama Sherry's big
laid-back family so when he's in the
ship the middle of service he slowed him
down like [__] Michael Jackson yes
yes
oh [__] yeah
I hate to ruin a good party but if you
want to run a successful business then
the terms
laid-back and professional just don't
mix
it's not just about how good the food
tastes it's about how it [__] gets
there as well and that is crucial
I can't wait to see this team of jokers
in action
all right so we get going because
they're hungry
immediately it's clear who's the mummer
in this kitchen I'm getting you a chili
pepper because you're able to know
just the one
can I take the seeds out at least
Sharita talks to them like they're her
children and she's the only one cooking
anything from fresh
[Music]
okay show me to all of the seconds uh
party you're in all right okay two
potato skins onions cornbread two pieces
can I get some jambalaya heated up
please
for Brian and 80 it's just an elaborate
Heating and plating up exercise mattings
of messy food School dinner style a
d-minus must try harder that's hot gravy
yeah on hot turkey serves on cold plates
with cold salad yep
what's he laughing at
about to kick off when
there's twice as many stars as there
need be
this should be an absolute Breeze but
should we just killing herself trying to
do everything in the basement
[Music]
paying two fully qualified chefs to
dress and send a plate of nachos come on
that's a Surefire way to break your
business
very very painful
several occasions you're standing here
cooking away in a world of your own yeah
and these guys standing there just
almost playing with themselves because
they're waiting for something from you
if you are the head chef yes then you're
gonna have to start taking the reins
yeah yeah I want to try and get through
a busy night
without pissing your pants with laughter
two hours pure concentration without
laughing okay and I bet you can't do it
I can't do it are you [__] smiling
already
if there was ever a case of too many
cooks this is it one of them will have
to go
[Music]
forever do not be scared to get rid of
baggage
Brighton's best kept secret Mama
Sherry's Soul Food shack is so well kept
it's losing a thousand pounds a week
knowing it 20 past 10 in the morning no
by day three I've uncovered a couple of
reasons why I know it's chilled but [__]
you know not as children as a snapper
why is no one here this time in the
morning it's ridiculous firstly the
food's good but it could be so much
better where's uh where's Brian let me
give you a hand Brian yeah I have no
idea
secondly there are far too many staff
and most of them aren't pulling their
weight
when he's late nothing nothing
I'm just gonna wash up right now
so you're washing up as well
she's in she opens up brings all the
supplies upstairs you should be ashamed
yourself
Brian
treat his next task is to make a huge
batch of macaroni cheese that will last
her for two whole weeks keep this going
oh this is coming up nicely
up on the stove her food is irresistible
people will travel Mars to taste it
but like a lot of our home cooking this
lot is destined for the freezer where
it's delicious texture and flavor will
be lost forever
understand why you want to freeze it
yeah it's so tasty well I think I don't
think I won it's not a case of one no I
think you've got into a habit I've
gotten a habit which is a lazy habit
you're not lazy because you work so
bloody
harder it's definitely lazy if you turn
up for work half an hour late in my
kitchen trust me you'd be home for the
day looking for a new [__] job
to be honest there's no wonder Brian's
lost heart the man's been working in the
kitchen for as long as I have but to
save money he's been sidelined
so much so he's rarely involved in
actually making any of the food
but you're throwing it together
the exact same way every single week so
when you're not doing it who does it I'm
doing it that's my point okay if Sharita
was using Brian properly they could
ditch the freezers once and for all and
the macaroni and cheese is nearly there
that looks delicious I think that should
go to star food yeah I think so it does
look good doesn't it as it stands few
customers will taste the food at its
best street has thrown away her unique
selling point
[Music]
boy does she need one
it's a ten past one Saturday lunchtime
and this place should be absolutely
round and there's not a soul in there
[Music]
this is Dyer Saturday and Sunday are
your Prime days for business but like
many failing restaurants Sharita is
making some classic mistakes Poor Man's
meat pie yeah eight pounds yeah I know
it's gonna be good yeah you go onto the
menu here you've got main courses at 14
yeah 15 pounds why they gone up so
expensive
um to pay my bills to be blunt it was
bank manager yeah
um accounting and I was saying help me
help me how do I do this they say You're
Gonna raise your prices you've got to
raise your prices always the bank
manager's solution yeah and it was it
was literally down to the bank manager
well he's an [__] okay yeah it's
killing the business I want to look at
restructuring the menu okay making it a
little bit shorter okay
tweaking the portion size all right
having less comeback 60 and our bones
come back but it's that 40 I'm going to
work on the objective for every customer
come through that door is to have a
starter yeah a Mains and a dessert okay
you wait and see the turnover treble if
you can squeeze three courses out of
them okay
but before we can squeeze anything out
of anybody we need customers and if
they're not coming to us we've got to
take Mama Sherry's finger licking food
to them so got the meatloaf oh my yeah
got the ribs yeah okay got the chicken
that smells amazing oh smelling so good
so that
and who better to flaunt it than the
mama herself don't be shy whoa
I'm gonna come to you since you're not
coming to me
at Mama Cherry Soul Food shack just
around the corner there
I'm pretty pretty good this particular
food is called soul food okay cooked
from the soul from the heart boy she's
good a soul food evangelist and she's
out to convert the whole of Brighton
can I hear you all
whole food all right just wind her up
and let her go
get me small Wings all right don't
forget this time it's on the house next
time they're paying you yep yes I did
there's no doubt that street is a
terrific cook but she's employing Brian
to do that job and I'm beginning to
realize she's wasted in the kitchen
[Music]
just call me Mama
you got it
with Saturday night's service about to
begin it's time to get this Shack in
order
it's pretty obvious that the business is
in Dire Straits you know that's real
that's real that's the truth watching
you guys over the last couple of days
you actually treat it like it's your
[__] home chilled relaxed and this
lady here you talk to her almost as if
it's your mum
and that really has to stop if this is
going to go any further and if it
doesn't work not only are you out of
business the libraryhood's gone yeah all
of you guys are out of a [__] job
you've got no work so when it's that far
down we really have to dig deep and come
up with sensible ideas and tonight I'm
going to ask you to stay out the kitchen
okay you've got so much to sell yeah and
you you're a [__] good cook I think
so Sharita let him cook I'm gonna let
him I am good you have to pass the reins
over now and if you don't break away
from this stove I swear to God the
business is going to close and let them
do the job that you [__] pay the
money for okay yeah yep I'm gonna go put
some makeup on because I'm going
downstairs Street hustling has secured a
fully booked Russian tonight if we're
gonna get through it we need to get this
kitchen working like an efficient
well-oiled machine
Time to whip up a bit of professionalism
into these boys uh Gavin can you say
those starters and food downstairs yeah
I'm standing there doing nothing there
you go five thank you okay he's standing
there yeah open up your eyes yeah and
get him [__] working okay you're
running this place tonight you know that
yeah you're gonna prove her downstairs
that you can do it and not just to her
but yourself and me I said no smiling no
laughing serious okay yes yeah let's go
she's still smiling now
good evening have you had a chance to
look at the menu yeah
downstairs Serita slipped effortlessly
into the role of the hostess with the
most tests and if you eat macaroni and
cheese
it's fantastic
coordinated my jeans
Brian's taking his first decision as a
head chef pre-cooked buffalo wings are
off the menu from now on they're being
cooked to order chicken's been good from
fresh that's nice people already have
places to stand around in 20 minutes
well almost the rest of the food's going
out just as Cerritos always done it hot
food cold plate uninspiring salads
[Music]
that's shocking and you're breaking
meatloaf
but let's not try to run before we can
walk can I get this one as soon as
possible
how long
[Music]
but now she's front of house treated
using every trick in the book to boost
business five minutes
okay thank you okay
two hours in and the food's not going
out quick enough shrita's faith in brine
is dwindling fast these guys have been
in a long time I got kids down there
yeah but their status have just gone
okay
what happened there no starters they're
done so already in the lift yeah yeah
these ones well I'm doing them now oh
[__] I just told her they're gone man
for Prime three years of living the
canary coma is a hard habit to break
he's beginning to lose it
still waiting on their starters
aren't exactly helping come on Brian
don't lose it now here no what else on
this table I need to see what's on it
hot wings and barbecue chicken wings I
need whatever else is there because they
are getting restless
a good 14-20 minutes to make sure that
you know you don't kill anyone okay as
that pig feet go on because it needs to
go on now because it takes the time yeah
every minute you're in here we're losing
money
[__] hell
so what do you think of that Meatloaf
that'd be good thank you didn't I tell
you didn't I tell you I thought the
kitchen got off to a really good start
you were slightly nervous being down
there because you were sort of not
spying on them but coming up agitated
yeah yeah you lost it Brian a little bit
and things just got a little bit you
said something interesting though
yeah I'm Trudeau has to understand it's
going to take three or four minutes
longer because I'm cooking from raw and
the benefit is the customer but I think
this guy yeah with the help of 80 can
get faster yeah much much faster I mean
how would you sum up you're in the
dining room tonight it felt good because
I'm telling you for three and a half
years being it was the first Saturday
night that I have spent downstairs
they've seen you you know that's the
face they want to see when they come to
see Mama downstairs I'm gonna be
cracking the whip a lot harder it's your
business of course I was thinking you
know I gotta crack it let's go okay
thank you good thank you guys let me go
down here sand because I got a few more
desserts to sell yeah
if Brian's going to win sharita's
respect as a head chef he needs to
become more involved in preparing the
food as well as cooking it number 13
lucky for some
but since these hours were cut he's been
dropped in a catch-22 situation where's
little lady on
hey Brian's been left holding the baby
it became a problem with this Claire had
to go to work yeah and we had to find a
way of meeting the bill at the end of
the month yeah you know and that's why
uh I can't do Tuesdays and Wednesdays
the whole thing is just confused yeah
you know as Brian's involvement with the
food has diminished so too has his
confidence
the first time he made meatloaf two
years ago it was a disaster so we're
going to prove that Brian can not only
do it but do it better how much
influence do you have on the menu even
sometimes I'll do a menu or something
but she changes it anyway so really at
the end of the my own points disappears
but you've got to be strong now yes
she's going to concentrate in the dining
room you're gonna be running the kitchen
you have to be strong yes yes
the problem with sharita's meatloaf is
the bacon by the time it's cooked it's
like cutting into leather
back bacon you saw dries out it's hardly
fat and bad bacon okay so you know It's
Tricky bacon
um Place one
nice fatty piece of bacon there as it's
cooking yeah it's putting moisture
exactly inside the meatloaf yeah
fantastic
you know if I put my foot down and said
no this is like this like that I think I
can see myself going far you know I can
achieve things it's a it's a happy
feeling you know
it's a Happy Feeling
just love them
the seasoning is just right it's not too
salty nice oh yeah it's fine it doesn't
need any does it need anything else
anything else at all
with Brian's confidence slowly returning
now I've got to work on Sharita
she excels as a natural cook and a great
hostess
oh my God
but when it comes to business she's a
self-confessed numbskull
and this tells me the money the money is
look out that's a bit shorter yeah we're
going the other way around I wanted the
other way around definitely but it's not
just the Takens that are the problem
here 200 grams of
like a beautifully risen cake successful
restaurants only Thrive with three key
business factors are working in close
harmony
200 grams of flour
we establish one third staff costs
one-third food costs and one-third gross
profit
combine all those ingredients into one
recipe yeah chemistry you have the most
amazing cake and that's how any good
business works yeah at the moment
Sarita's business cake is way off course
we'll show you something what we've got
currently happening here at the show
with few midweek customers Shooters
gross profits are dangerously low very
very little profit her food costs are
reasonably healthy but a massive
overheads are crippling her
well I just want to show that was going
to cost you when we start adding really
high staff costs so there's an imbalance
already yep bloody hard now I'm doing
this on purpose to prove a point yeah
can't complete a recipe for successful
business when you've got imbalanced
situation
you can tell me to [__] off but how much
do you pay yourself a month a month uh
well I get around 200 a week that's it
I'm the lowest side of the kitchen 200
pounds a week a week yeah 800 pounds a
month you're working seven days a week
I'm working seven days a week that's a
[__] disgrace I'm an 80 kids more
than me some weeks
a common Chef that's part-time gets paid
more than you
far too [__] soft
oh you really are far too soft well it
stops now I know I know I know I know I
know I know
that is a profitable business with the
right ingredients yeah yeah that is what
you're currently running right have a
think and let me know which one you'd
like to eat
[Applause]
why are you crying
because I'm not going to lose my
business
[Music]
I'm nearing the end of my week in
Brighton
[__] bullets sure I found my soul yet
but Brian is finally beginning to behave
like a head chef
[Music]
and charito is undergoing a
transformation from mother to matron and
from now on she'll be ruling this Roost
with an iron hand it is not a drop in
Center
but we still have a fundamental problem
a crippling lack of weekday customers
what we need is a gimmick a bargain that
will ensure the Shacks fall to the
rafters all week long the idea is is to
sell your restaurant per table okay okay
so table of six six chairs yep ten pound
ahead 60 pound for that table if that
worked yeah every night at 10 pound
ahead yeah that's 360 pounds in the till
think of it this way yeah they'll spend
the same amount of money on their
alcohol on alcohol
my plan is to create an exciting
three-course fixed buffet for each table
so find the service and cherry picking
from the existing menu okay but before
we do the big presentation to Sharita
I've got to inject some life into those
god-awful limp salads
how much does salad cost on the menu
four pound [__] 50. do you think
that's real good value for money for
what you're serving
no no made a very simple dressing here
roasted cumin yes yeah a little bit
olive oil fresh lime okay look at the
difference now
stop building it up and get some colors
in there yeah four pound fifty for a
salad it's a [__] joke
um sweet potatoes uh huge and soul food
yeah all they've done has been blanched
yes into the pan yeah
nicely colored don't move them until
they've got color on there okay the more
you move them around what happens
let's break up that boys in the
background she's in the kitchen again
and I need the secret here now is to
keep them nice and hot they go really
nice almost like a roast potato yeah
it's not a difficult finicky thing to do
for me you know when you look at the
style of sweetest food it's really
important to keep it rustic don't want
anything fancy I'm not being funny but
Gavin the kitchen Porter you can get
this stuff done yes huh
oh that is good damn
I'm in heaven what I'm trying to do is
make the place look less cluttered yes
the food speaks for itself and sometimes
I see these mountains of food going on
okay yeah and you know it's too much
okay yeah there you go lick it oh and
you know you'll want to
what can I say cousin Gordon sweet
potato salad yeah yeah that's what it's
gonna be called
as long as it's delicious and looks good
the customers are going to love it yeah
[Music]
Brian can clear the Frozen backlog and
start from afresh make it look nice yeah
we've got to sell this yeah
[Music]
simple sexy and irresistible soul food
salsa as well come on then do it now
you're driving around the bend you know
that 80 what do you think
table of four
huh [__] good
this is fantastic honestly what
leftovers right now
fried Teresa yeah basically we've gone
through the fridge I think we'll need to
be used up yes and every day is going to
change yes here we just made a really
nice uh vegetable
um Pig Lily and it just marinades
through brown sugar and vinegar look at
that there for four people yeah you've
got a mug of soup as well don't forget I
think it's quite sort of fresh on you
yeah and it sort of deformalizes the
restaurant because it is soul food and
it's you know across the table yeah yeah
I think it also introduces everybody to
a different stuff all the food so
everyone is having different Taste of
everything yeah and the idea of course
is one they've experienced this they've
come back Friday or Saturday yeah for a
full day yeah yeah this looks great good
I like that tomorrow we're going live oh
don't worry I'm gonna be now you said
live you wait I'm Gonna Be Live
it seems to eat as well and truly sold
on our new idea
we'll make a word up but I guess I can't
call it slappers because that sounds too
rude
laughs
[Music]
and short Dynamics yeah to the point
yeah yeah the Mama's on a crusade right
okay customers it's all in a bowl all
right and we're launching tomorrow
evening having a big party down there 10
pounds each three courses delicious
okay I'm doing ribs jambalaya barbecue
chicken going yeah bring some friends
with you okay I love the food fantastic
by tomorrow night Sherita wants the
whole of West Sussex to know about
Mama's cherries
the best non-stop wrapping up with
brand new midweek eating concept soul in
a bowl
give me some of this this is ribs okay
here we go yeah gorgeous absolutely
lovely you eat I'll talk okay when
you're hungry and you need of a serious
food attack just come to Mama cherries
the Soul Food shack we've got soul in a
bowl three yummy courses served on a
platter fried chicken jambalaya and more
we're talking soul food Tapas the price
is so right so come to the shack tonight
as soon as you brought us breakfast you
have that huge plug for nothing thank
you
would be lucky to get eight customers
can I help you but whilst we've been out
bookings for this evening's launch have
gone through the roof
settings
it's all coming together except for One
Small Hitch
there's no Brian there's no 80 there's
no Gavin no one's here Brian's stuck
with a [__] babysitter somewhere God
knows where and um you know what if ever
gonna get this place right then they're
gonna have to really understand
discipline because this is a joke big
day no one in the [__] kitchen
where have you been
yeah I thought we're gonna be here by
10. I wasn't
yeah she said no I said no God just like
that out of the blue get changed yeah
and let's get [__] started yeah let's
kill you
I was hoping the renewed responsibility
of running this kitchen would re-light
Brian's passion for cooking you need
young man eggs [__] rocket up your
ass and with it bring a new commitment
to both raising the quality and the
urgency with which the food's delivered
how about sweating off the onions at the
same time they're in front of their look
okay there you go
but even if Brian was making the new
improved meatloaf twice as fast
they still wouldn't be quick enough
I'm just testing it now to see what uh
flavors have come up sure we haven't put
the wet mixture in there yet so how can
you identify the texture oh yes
get the recipe complete first and the
breadcrumb then do the [__] test
Jesus Christ some mothers do have them
and I've got one
thankfully street is completely unaware
that Brian's already losing it upstairs
so how's it looking now um it's looking
for another day of the week oh my
Wednesday this is wonderful they're
perfect and 50. 55 cancel tonight that's
550 pound food yep the same again yep
hopefully on the drink drink yeah that's
a thousand pound in the till which is
equivalent to a Friday night two yeah
that's a Friday night show a touch of
flexibility it's the new start for the
shack and tonight every member of
Sharita staff has got to give 100 okay
here are a set of rules that each and
every one of you are now going to abide
by and it's not a governing rule it's an
understanding what this business needs
to go further and forward I need
everybody here on time and on time means
if I say you start at six you get here
at quarter two that way you have your
cigarettes you get change you chat you
have your coffee and so that at six
o'clock you're on the floor okay the
next one is there is always something to
do if you can't think of it ask me the
queen is now in Residence yes exactly
Sarita is now on the floor
I'm going to be and to confirm that
we're going to raise the flag yes okay
okay
there you go
have a great service think customer push
the wine and work together let's get it
right right [__] now let's go okay
inside
the success of soul in a bowl relies on
doing large numbers at only 10 pound
ahead Sharita must fill the restaurant
twice over everything prepped yes are
you nervous yeah I am good it's a good
sign start shooting yourself Brian Eddie
and Gavin I've got to get those platters
flying down those stairs but they're
only just peeling the last potatoes
send you down a tray design for two you
can cook cornbread and soup with soup as
a starter
all right thank you unfortunately we are
fully book tonight
first Wednesday night ever they've had
to turn customers away slightly spicy
sweet potato soup table three two meat
tapas
okay just to bring it up to them
[Music]
that you've got up there it's down is
three they've had a person join them so
it's now before it's already looking
better but tonight it's got to be
perfect take the [__] Bowl off I'll
try put it in the bowl yeah I'm throwing
all the [__] on there everywhere yeah
we're nice and clean
[__] clean come on yeah
and for the first time this week Brian's
not smiling that is lovely Well Done
Right vegetarian please Daddy send it
away so now we're looking for a full
soup and a tree soup four cornbread tree
cornbread Gavin you're taking care of
the desserts yeah
team is pulling together
[Music]
if we slide down I'm gonna lose it
communication is much much better can I
get a timing on some of these so I can
tell them five minutes five minutes
at eight o'clock so far so good yeah did
a good job if they can keep it going we
might just pull this one off
they said they are stuffed it was
delicious all of the different flavors
that go with it fully satisfied I'm
gonna take them some dessert you see
that empty bowls
for that dessert 80 surprises all with
his homemade pecan pies that was
delicious that big panel beating any day
you know that any day at just 40 Pence
to make each slice it's a fifth cheaper
and ten times tastier than the ones
sharita's been buying in
things must be going okay because we've
hardly seen her in the kitchen all night
I'm starting to turn but I've got it
this is a crucial thing at 10 pound
ahead
so can we do two trays at the same time
is it possible you can yeah now the
pressure's really on come on let's get
some organization guys come on it's
still not perfect a table's called away
you stick that ticket on the tray no one
touches it but the vibe up here has
definitely got more professional we're
losing valuable time man what are you
doing
can't quite believe I'm saying this but
I think Brian's actually breaking a
sweat it's looking good they're loving
it people are loving it
very tasty very good food you got the
salads well done man thank you thank you
very much I haven't eaten anything quite
like this before and it's really nice
a six and a four then we're finished
it's remarkable let's get it going last
table goes out just like the first time
yes
I will come back left in Italy
definitely will come back
[Music]
[__] well done yeah everybody good
that's one day the real work starts
tomorrow yeah yeah let's go I didn't
know how much I was gonna cook today you
know
do you know if I was gonna cope
or break basically but just one photo of
my mind is to get through this
[Music]
Thursday morning and the whole team are
in early
[Music]
we gotta get that well going
the clean out of food stocks and fully
booked tonight so they're starting
completely from scratch
[Music]
home cooking Straight From the Soul
Hallelujah
can I just say you sent me a Target yes
when I spoke to you last night we hadn't
reached that time 300 pound last night
yeah I asked for a thousand when I
cashed up I hit 1 000. uh it was 1080.
55 these two
yeah they did it 80s quietly impressed
me this week
but if he really wants to make it as a
chef he's got to decide where his
loyalties lie no I do I do enjoy it but
I don't think I don't like the hours I
don't want to be working those sort of
hours aren't they unless I'm as rich as
you
[Music]
can I just say one as your age at the
age of 20 yeah there wasn't enough
rounds in the [__] day for me to work
so
um yeah I'd be very happy to become
successful but you got to work for
everyone it doesn't just come on a plate
where you've got to read the following
it'll happen
and Brian well the success of Mama
Sherry's depends on his strength and his
commitment more than anybody's you've
really pissed me off this week you know
that yes I felt really
but after especially yesterday when I
realized that I haven't been really
sort of it's like I didn't care almost I
just thought when I first saw you in the
kitchen you're treating it like a job no
passion but last night it came back and
I could feel it you are the head chef
yes so act like the head chef yes take
responsibilities as a head chef yes get
a grip wake up and [__] stop dreaming
yeah and I think Sharita knows what she
must do you are the most Marvel asset
yeah
well I might be selling myself now I'm
in my kitchen understand kitchen morning
a.m hosting the room and being present
in the evening you have got to continue
that I will do then I've got to take
some control back send me a [__]
example do not be scared to get rid of
baggage
thank you
back in December I spent a week at Mama
Sherry's failing Soul Food shack and
I've never spent a week quite like it
no discipline if you turn up for work
half an hour late in my kitchen you'd be
home for the day looking for a new
[__] job
000 pound in debt every minute you're in
here we're losing money
[Music]
serious okay yeah you need young man
thanks [__] rocket of your ass and
the mama found her true calling if you
don't break away from the stove
just call me Mama
you got it together by the end of the
week we have the shack firmly back on
track see that empty bowls
it's a Wednesday night and I'm just
hoping the mama will be glad to have me
back
hello oh my God
my cousin here in the dining room of
course where else would I be I'm out of
the kitchen and soul in the bowl
still going going down I mean I wish you
could have been here last night we were
absolutely full well Tuesday on a
Tuesday upstairs and downstairs yeah
it's a lot better you see Lauren's
actually in a uniform hi Lauren uh were
you late today no no no I came in early
today actually
oh yes I know yeah my Moonwalker where
is he oh he's upstairs he's upstairs
yeah yeah go a little surprise them it's
great to hear that Brian sorted out his
babysitting problems
has been able to take him on full time
as Mama Cherry's head chef and he's a
changed man
how you doing big boy are you well good
to see you it's nice to see you again on
weekdays he's running the kitchen
single-handed and he seems to be
thriving on the responsibility
that looks fantastic
you're not throwing things in there
anymore now you place them in there
nicely they actually looks nice it looks
better huh it does yes what's happened
to you over the last two months I went
through uh face like I mean
the Lord's come down and touched you had
given up all credit to Brian he's taken
soul in a bowl and run with it it's
looking really fresh
also get you get starters and you get a
choice of nachos or soup
nachos nachos nachos
how long does it take you now for food
to come out on the tray on the train
sticking a bar at least I would say
about six seven minutes give me five
minutes so quick quick as possible as I
can be yeah
so you haven't lost your touch then no
no not really it's coming back slowly
you know when you lose a bit of
confidence it's kind of difficult too so
try and find yourself back again you
know but at the moment I'm so into it
and I'm gonna get it done whatever
happens
okay here we go the team has been
stripped down and the customers seem to
love their new improved food it's all
good for business
got some jerk chicken your meat
jambalaya hot wings barbecue January's
takings are up a staggering 60 on last
year despite now being closed on a
Monday and last Saturday Street have
filled the restaurant three times over
with Brian and Aidy cooking for a
massive
105 customers I'd love to see you
spinning around doing 105 covers you
know that yeah I bet you're moonwalking
all over the [__] I didn't see the
moon for a second there
okay
soul in the bowl
thank you oh let's see what we got here
for you tonight Brian as well is exactly
what I wanted him to get some confidence
and he's got that self-confidence I walk
in and see what you've done to the menu
they look fantastic
fun and I've also
Christmas no intimidation yeah and you
know when I think back to that folder
and go through those pages yeah yeah and
all that crap on that yeah it was like a
book but I think it was it was too much
difference
what's happening now is I've got people
coming on the weekdays ordering the song
in the bowl and then they say to me I
can't wait to book a weekend because I
know now I'm having those ribs they
weren't enough so I have words you were
yeah what wasn't happening in the
business actually well that stress has
gone that the stress is gone because now
I feel that there is a future before
anything that was a future I've got that
fire back inside of me yeah
and you know where the business go yeah
and I know where where it's going and
we're in Canada yeah so are you making
the perfect [__] sponge cake
do you remember that one yes I know you
do I will never forget that why so if
you have to put it together now why
would it come out of your cake my cake
will come out better than your cake
that means you're cooking the books
Long Live Mama cherry and her finger
licking food I'll definitely be back for
more
great
I bet you you can't make it
make it 20 meters centimeters you're
full of [__] you know that okay go for
it
tired no no no not yet
are you a little tired you [__] win
still darling I know give us a spin give
us a spin speed
[Music]